see the world's most powerful  superheroes in the world's most  immersive film experience  don't miss Dark Phoenix in IMAX in June  get your tickets today what is this  place  welcome to the school for the gifted we  are now seeing the beginnings of another  stage of human evolution  the truth is mutants are very real and  they are among us  here you have the chance to be part of  something much bigger than yourself  forget everything you think you know  you're not kids anymore  [Music]  you're x-men the wars still coming  Charles and I intend to fight it you are  so nice you ready for this a new  tomorrow starts today the world is on  the brink  [Music]  changing what  when is controller  but it feels  [Music]  tell me how we fix this truck don't know  what to do me that's right  the right to fear me  you